how do you
from the scientific perspective go from
knowing nothing about the disease
to going you said to go into the entire
pipeline and actually have a drug or
or a treatment that cures that disease
so that's
an enormously long path and an
enormously great
challenge and what i'm trying to argue
is that
it progresses in stages of understanding
rather than one gene at a time the
traditional view of biology was you have
one postdoc working on this gene
and another prosthetic working on that
gene and
they'll just figure out everything about
that gene and that's their job
what we've realized is how polygenic the
diseases are so we can't have one
postdoctoral gene anymore we now have to
have
these cross-cutting needs
and i'm going to describe the path to
circuitry
along those needs and every single one
of these paths
we are now doing in parallel across
thousands of genes
so the first step is you have a genetic
association
and we talked a little bit about sort of
the mendelian path
and the polygenic path to that
association so the mendelian path was
looking through families
to basically find gene regions
and ultimately genes that are underlying
particular disorders
the polygenic path is basically looking
at
unrelated individuals in this giant
matrix of genotype by phenotype
and then finding hits where particular
variant impacts disease
all the way to the end and then we now
have
a connection not between a gene and a
disease
but between a genetic region and a
and that distinction is not understood
by most people
so i'm going to explain it a little bit
more
why do do we not have a connection
between a gene
and a disease but we have a connection
between a genetic region and a disease
the reason for that is that 93
of genetic variants that are associated
with disease
don't impact the protein at all
so if you look at the human genome
there's 20 000 genes there's 3.2 billion
nucleotides only 1.5
of the genome codes for proteins
the other 98.5 percent
does not code for proteins if you now
look at where
are the disease variants located
93 of them fall in that
outside the genes portion of course
genes are enriched
but they're only rich by a factor of
three
that means that still 93 of genetic
variants
fall outside the proteins
why is that difficult why is that a
problem the problem is that
when a variant falls outside the gene
you don't know what gene is impacted by
that variant you can't just say oh
it's near this gene let's just connect
that variant to the gene
and the reason for that is that the
genome circuitry
is very often long range
so you basically have that genetic
variant that could sit in the intron
of one gene and an intron is sort of the
place between the axons that code for
proteins so proteins are split up
into exons and introns and every axon
codes for a
particular subset of amino acids and
together they're spliced together
and then make the final protein so that
genetic variant may be sitting in an
intron of a gene
it's transcribed with the gene it's
processed and then excised
but it might not impact this gene at all
it might actually impact
another gene that's a million
nucleotides away so it's just riding
along even though it has nothing to do
with the with this
nearby neighborhood that's exactly right
let me give you an example
the strongest genetic association with
obesity was discovered
in this fto gene fat and obesity
associated gene
so this fto gene was studied ad nauseum
people did tons of experiments on on it
they figured out that fto is in fact uh
rna methylation transferase it basically
crea it sort of impacts something that
we know that we call the epi
transcriptome
just like the genome can be modified the
transcriptome the transcripts of the
genes
can be modified and we basically said oh
great that means that that ap
transcriptomics is hugely involved in
obesity because that
that gene ftos is you know uh clearly
where the genetic locus
is at my group studied
fto in collaboration with you know a
wonderful team
uh led by melina klausmitzer and what we
found
is that this fto locus even though it is
associated with obesity does not
implicate the fto gene
the genetic variant sits in the first
intron of the fdo gene
but it controls two genes irx3
and ir x5 that are sitting 1.2
million nucleotides away several genes
away
oh boy uh what am i supposed to feel
about that because
isn't that like super complicated then
uh so the way that i was introduced at a
conference a few years ago
was uh and here's manolis kelly's who
wrote the most depressing paper
of 2015. and the reason for that is that
the entire pharmaceutical industry was
so comfortable
that there was a single gene in that
locus
because in some loci you basically have
three dozen genes that are all sitting
in the same
region of association and you're like
gosh which ones of those is it
but even that question of which ones of
those is it is making the assumption
that it is
one of those as opposed to some random
gene just far far away
which is what our paper showed so
basically what our paper showed is that
you can't ignore the circuitry you have
to first figure out the circuitry
all of those long-range interactions how
every genetic variant
impacts the expression of every gene in
every tissue imaginable
across hundreds of individuals and then
you now have one of the building blocks
not even all of the building blocks
for them going and understanding disease
so okay so so embrace
the the wholeness of the circuitry
correct but what
you